the seaside town of Torquay has long
been a popular haven for the elderly
this is war berries nursing home where
carers are doing their utmost to protect
vulnerable residents from the spread of
coronavirus the communal areas are
eerily quiet people are largely staying
in isolation in their rooms for their
own safety there's a strict no visiting
policy for relatives like so many other
homes war berries is battling dire staff
and equipment shortages but even more
worrying the homes owner has told Sky
News he's been asked to take in patients
from hospitals who are actively
suffering from ovid 19 very good reason
for that
that would be importing death into care
homes homes have done all the right
things against all the odds to add
insult to injury by asking us to take
cope with 19 positive patients is asking
us to basically make out the suicide
note for people in care this is one of
our lovely ladies giving out the tea
trolley staff took these videos of
themselves trying to maintain some
semblance of normality but nothing is
normal now least of all end-of-life care
so we've made an isolation
Lucey Hall is head of care and shows us
where they looked after a resident
suffering from a high temperature the
failure to carry out testing in care
homes means they'll never know for sure
whether he had coronavirus or not
because of that relatives weren't able
to be present when the 91 year old
passed away Howard his hand he says you
don't want to go anyway I don't know he
said he didn't want to be alone right
now so I sat with him but because of the
circumstances how many were able to be
with him so we had to be that person and
try and give him some form of dignity
and peaceful time within the last
moments of his life and that was really
hard really hard
Lucy's commitment to residents in the
home means she's had to stay away from
her own family that's been made even
more difficult because her grandfather
who has Parkinson's went into hospital
after a fall Lucy says he was put on a
ward with coronavirus patients but was
then sent home after testing positive my
heart broke because how can you do that
to somebody who's elderly they've got
Parkinson's yes that they are old but I
felt personally and as a family we felt
that they were basically sending him
home to die as the seasons pass
coronavirus is expected to keep
society's most vulnerable in isolation
for some time to come they may be out of
sight but carers say the elderly and the
vulnerable must not be forgotten Lisa
Holland Sky News talking